de retour sur europe 1 place au débat
d'europe me dit bonjour isabelle
florennes vous êtes porte parole du
modem et face à vous jonas haddad député
conseiller régional l'est républicain de
normandie vice-président de la fondation
concorde bonjour bonjour à vous alors un
document sur le budget 2023 été envoyée
aux parlementaires hier il prévoit
d'après le calcul du journal les échos
une hausse de 15 milliards d'euros de
dépenses par rapport au budget de l'an
dernier le gouvernement envisage de
mettre le paquet comme on dit sur la
formation le travail et les pour
l'éducation nationale ces trois secteurs
voient leurs crédits nettement augmenté
339 milliards d'euros de budget au total
est-ce que c'est raisonnable quand le
déficit public dépasse 100 14% du
produit intérieur brut
2009 101 milliards d'euros isabelle
florennes c'est surtout
indispensable c'est un engagement d'un
majorité présidentielle du président de
la république durant sa campagne que
nous avons soutenu avec le modem est
indispensable ça fait des années
notamment sur la question de l'éducation
et du salaire des enseignants nous nous
battons pour des revalorisations il
n'est pas normal que la france paye
aussi mal ces enseignants c'est quand
même pas normal de se retrouver dans le
peloton que au niveau européen et est
donc un engagement très concret c'est de
dire qu'il y aura pas de salaire des
enseignants à moins de 1000 euros c'est
ce qu'a annoncé le ministre des comptes
publics abrial attal et moi
personnellement et en tout cas pour
m'être battue pendant quelques années
sur les bancs de l'assemblée sur cette
question la revalorisation des salaires
des enseignants je pense que c'est c'est
quelque chose de très concret qui va
être visible sur lequel j'espère qu'il y
aura un accord à l'assemblée nationale
parce que vous savez très bien que peu
avec cette majorité relative il faut
trouver des accords et j'espère que nous
les trouverons notamment avec avec des
des députés aient l'air dans les mois
qui viennent en tout cas sur cette
question d'éducation est question de la
formation les questions l'an passé
indispensable pour mener une politique à
moyen et long terme en faveur de
l'emploi dans notre pays former des
bonnes personnes revalorisation continue
et élargissement encore de
l'apprentissage on veut effectivement
arriver à un million de contrats
d'apprentissage sur le mandat je pense
que c'est un très bon objective on sait
que ça a marché sous la précédente
mandature donc il faut continuer dans
cette direction que je salue les hausses
envisagées et la négociation est wass
entamé dès le mois de septembre avec les
partenaires et avec la première ministre
madame bornes sur le sujet et je
souhaite qu'on puisse trouver des
accords genas haddad vous qui est un un
représentant de la formation avec
laquelle la majorité
présidentielle trouve des compromis qu
envisage de faire les députés les
républicains face à ce budget de 339
milliards d'euros
paris envisage de faire ce qu'ils ont
fait depuis qu'ils sont illustrés dit en
gros ne pas être une opposition stérile
mais être une opposition constructive
lorsqu'on n'est pas d'accord on propose
une solution alternative est très
souvent d'ailleurs le gouvernement
adopte notre solution alternative ça a
été le cas notamment concernant le prix
à la pompe on a d'ailleurs communiquer
sur ce sujet puisque grâce à la
mobilisation des députés républicains
les gens vont payer moins à la au prix à
la pompe ce qu'on peut relever dans le
budget qui a été présentée d'abord
effectivement vous le disiez madame tout
à l'heure c'est intéressant de voir
augmenter le budget de l'éducation
nationale mais attention en matière
d'éducation al le budget ne fait pas
tous nos auditeurs doit savoir que le
budget de l'éducation nationale ça a
toujours été le premier budget de l'état
depuis depuis des dizaines d'années la
difficulté c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'on décroche dans les classements et
c'est effectivement là où on est
l'argent c'était en gros peut-être pas
faire comme françois hollande à l'époque
embaucher massivement des enseignants
mais plutôt les revaloriser donc ça ça
peut être des points qui avec lesquels
nous nous sommes en accord
en revanche là on n'est pas d'accord
c'est que les sources d'économies reste
vraiment mystérieuse pour le moment et
vous fait écho justement à cet article
des échos pour l'instant les seules
réductions de dépenses publiques
notamment sur un train de vie de l'état
qui est trop important qui sont faites
ça va être les réductions sur le plan de
relance et sur les aides pour les
entreprises qui a été atteinte par le
cos vide à côté de ça on n'a pas un
grand plan de réduction de la dépense
publique la seule autre plan de
réduction de la dépense publique est
envisagé c'est de raboter les dotations
aux collectivités locales pour que nos
auditeurs comprennent c'est en gros
retirer de l'argent aux mairies aux
départements et aux régions et on n'a
pas de plan le dire voilà comment on va
faire pour économiser de l'argent on n'a
pas de pot le mans par exemple contre la
fraude sociale qui est une fraude
massive on n'a pas de plan contre la
fraude fiscale qui est une fraude
massive et c'est pour ça que moi je le
dis de façon un petit peu ironique me
voyez par exemple le grand plan france
2030 qui est annoncé et bien le
gouvernement dans le budget qui est
annoncé il est obligé déjà dans de le
mettre en pause et donc en fait ça veut
dire que le plan qui était annoncé pour
être le plan france 2030
ben pour l'instant on voit que c'est
plutôt un plan france 2023 ça fait un an
quoi ça va durer sap a duré huit ans a
duré seulement un an donc on sera
extrêmement vigilant par rapport à ça
pour arriver à la fois un budget qui
remet le paquet comme vous le disiez
tout à l'heure sur l'éducation et sur
l'emploi mais ne pas oublier de faire
des réductions dans les dépenses
publiques qui sont inutiles et pardon de
le dire mais c'est quand même important
parce que c'est toujours un impensé dans
le gouvernement actuel un trou noir en
quelque sorte je regarde le budget
sécurité en est seulement le huitième
budget et je pense que personne en
france elle ne peut considérer que les
événements qui ont lieu de voilà au
moins les 12 derniers mois ne démontre
pas qu'il faudrait aussi mettre le
paquet comme on l'a dit alors sur la
sécurité isabelle briand rennes où sont
les économies alors je voudrais juste
redire quand même deux trois choses n'a
par rapport à
viens de dire monsieur haddad
s'est d'ailleurs c'est d'abord une
présentation budgétaire qui se situe
dans la limite des 5 % de déficit
autorisés et le ministre l'a bien
rappelé ensuite les pistes d'économie il
y en a il y en a eu déjà annoncés
précédemment et on sait très bien que
dans des mesures effectivement de
soutien qui ont eux qui existent et qui
ont existé notamment pendant la crise qu
vide celles ci seront réduites dès 2023
ministre de l'économique et la fin du
conte sur mille de secteurs mais pour
l'instant effectivement ça fera partie
aussi de cette discussion que nous
aurons échos orale gouvernement à partir
du mois de septembre avec avec ses
partenaires sur la question des
collectivités locales moi je peux pas
laisser dire qu'il n'y a pas d'efforts
qui ont été faits envers les
collectivités locales qui ont été
toujours entièrement compensée sur les
dotations donc peux pas vous laisser
dire qu'il ya des baisses de dotations
peux pas vous laisser dire non plus
puisque c'est l'accord qui a été trouvé
en cmp la semaine dernière je tiens le
rappeler entre le sénat et l'assemblée
nationale que 22 milles
communes ont été et vont être compensés
sur notamment les hausses prévues pour
les fonctionnaires et notamment les
fonctionnaires territoriaux donc on ne
peut pas dire qu'il n'y ait pas d'effort
qu'ils soient faits sur ces
compensations d'augmentation de salaires
notamment des 3 5% d'augmentation qui
ont été votées pour pour les
fonctionnaires en général et puis
dernière chose sur la sécurité non on ne
peut pas dire que ce gouvernement n'est
pas investi et une fois de plus le
budget prévoit que les ministères
régaliens c'est à dire la justice et la
sécurité notamment soit font partie des
ministères et des budgets qui vont être
et qui sont qui le sont depuis quelques
années constamment revalorisé donc
vous allez pouvoir répondre à isabelle
florennes mais juste avant
marque une petite pause une petite pause
d'informations voici le rappel de
l'essentiel de l'actualité avec
guillaume burgaud jean guillot bonjour
après bonjour à tous environ 3000
personnes évacuées cette nuit dans
l'aveyron après le déclenchement d'un
incendie à l'est de rodez il s'agit du
même feu de forêt qui s'est déclenché
hier en lozère et qui s'est propagée aux
départements voisins pour l'heure il
n'est pas question pour les personnes
évacuées de retrouver leur domicile 600
pompiers luttent contre les flammes qui
ont détruit 700 hectares de végétation
dans le sud de la charente un incendie
est également en cours 150 hectares déjà
brûlé 30 personnes ont quitté leur
domicile plus de 200 pompiers mobilisés
pour éteindre le feu météo france laisse
donc pour aujourd'hui quatre
départements en vigilance orange
canicule le lot et garonne la gironde le
vaucluse et le gard les températures
restent élevées avec des pointes pouvant
aller jusqu'à 39 degrés dans le sud
ouest l'armée taïwanaise débute un
exercice d'art tiré à balles réelles
simulant la défense de lille contre une
invasion chinoise plusieurs centaines de
soldats ont d'ailleurs été déployés
ainsi qu'une quarantaine d'autres dire
nouvel exercice est prévue jeudi cela
fait suite à pékin qui mène en ce moment
plusieurs importantes opérations
militaires aériennes et maritimes autour
de taïwan en réponse rapport à la visite
de nancy pelosi la villa de donald trump
enfin en floride perquisitionné ce matin
par le vieil le républicain liés de près
ou de loin à plusieurs dossiers
judiciaires n'en a pas précisé la raison
mais selon les médias américains
interventions relèvent d'une enquête sur
la mauvaise gestion de documents
classifiés merci beaucoup guillaume but
ans qui vous accompagne vous informe
toute la journée sur europe 1 et ce
jusqu'à 17 heures
le débat d'europe midi avec isabelle
floren porte parole du modem jonas
haddad conseiller régional l'est
républicain de normandie vice-président
de la fondation concorde jonas à date je
me tourne vers vous isabelle florennes
vous disait que le gouvernement investit
dans les collectivités locales et dans
la sécurité surtout
pour écouter évidemment moi je ne
m'attendais pas une autre réponse que ça
après ces deux revendications que je
portais tout à l'heure c'est une
revendication qui est porté par
quasiment tous les partis politiques à
part cela la majorité présidentielle
donc c'est une revendiquant une
revendication qui est partagée même par
des acteurs de gauche par la présidente
de la rade et des régions de france qui
est qui et carole delga qui est
socialiste mais mais mais peu important
je pense que ce qui
ce sur quoi on doit ce
réussir à converger c'est de se dire
comment on peut faire pour que le
gouvernement qui a eu l'habitude dans le
précédent quinquennat il faut il faut le
dire et même d'ailleurs bruno le maire
l'a dit il faut changer une méthode qui
a été pris l'habitude d'être un peu
autarcique puisse entendre les choses
qu'on propose et là dedans je n'ai pas
entendu toujours de plans de réductions
de dépenses publiques et pourquoi ne pas
saisir au bond des propositions des
républicains on en a parlé tout à
l'heure la fraude sociale par exemple
c'est 50 milliards de dépenses en france
il ya eu des des rapports qui sont très
clairs là dessus des millions de
personnes disposent de cartes vitale
alors king qui ne vivent plus en france
ou alors qu'il n'existe même plus qui
sont déjà décédés alors je laisse aller
vous avez réussi à imposer au
gouvernement la création d'une carte
vitale biométrique 20 millions de
crédits ont été accordés dans le dernier
projet de loi de finances rectificative
ce grâce aux sénateurs les républicains
bruno retailleau en tête
absolument et en fait c'est sur des
démarches comme ça on appelle ça un peu
des démarches commando voyez on sait
qu'on pourra pas bouger globalement la
ligne du gouvernement sur un certain
nombre de choses je vous parlait alors
de la sécurité on a essayé md min entre
guillemets de droite qui sont mais au
final ben en fait tant qu au niveau du
chef de l'état ça ne bougera pas dans sa
tête ce sera compliqué mais sur ces
sujets on va pousser ses amendements
vous verrez par exemple est noté nos
auditeurs le verrons à la pompe à la
rentrée il y aura des baisses sur sur le
prix à la pompe à côté de ça il faut
faire extrêmement attention aussi aux
dosages de la suppression des aides vous
savez les deux dernières années ça peut
paraître assez contre intuitif il ya eu
seulement 35 mille faillite par an alors
que d'habitude il y en a 70 milles et si
on retire pour prendre une image un
petit peu dur mais si on retire trop
rapidement la perfusion et bien on peut
avoir un mur des faillites qui va être
compliqué je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
d'emprunter de l'argent et pour les
entreprises et les entrepreneurs qui
nous écoutent le savent et donc il faut
être peut-être un petit peu plus doux
sur la façon dont on retire la seringue
qui a permis à nos entreprises de
survivre et donc de continuer à avoir de
l'emploi voilà et à côté de ça et moi je
le dis très clairement parce qu'on n'est
pas des opposants la bête et méchant moi
je pense qu'il faut saluer ce qui est
fait en matière d'emploi parce que
aujourd'hui le principal problème des
gens c'est pas de trouver un travail
globalement en tout cas c'est notamment
aux recruteurs de recruter et on le voit
tous autour de nous et avant un grand
plan massif pour que le recrutement soit
plus facile et une incitation à
reprendre un travail parce que leur
rapport au travail a beaucoup changé
après le coc vide avec l'émergence du
télétravail ce rapport au travail qui
fragmentent et ça c'est quelque chose de
bien sur lequel on pourra apporter notre
pierre à l'édifice isabelle flou règne
oui alors moi je voulais juste revenir
sur sur deux trois choses que kddi
monsieur haddad sur la fraude sociale
s'est pas c'est pas un sujet nouveau et
gouvernement et des parlementaires se
sont attaqués aux sujets déjà depuis
quelques temps avec des missions
parlementaires et maintenant une lettre
de mission ministérielle qui est en
cours avec un plan justement qui est en
cours il faut cependant je crois
vraiment être très très prudent avec les
chiffres annoncés et les chiffres que
vous annoncez monsieur malheureusement
ne sont pas juste me semble utile donc
moi je garderai bien ils sont très très
difficile à évaluer je connais des
missions parlementaires qui ont
travaillé depuis de longue date cette
dernière mandature sur ces questions
notamment au sénat et je voudrais dire
juste l'incité à la prudence il ya une
mission ministérielle qui est qui qui va
être lancé visiblement et un plan qui
est en cours c'est un sujet sur lequel
parlementaires et gouvernement
travaillons il y a que trois mille
cartes en trop selon les chiffres de la
cnac de la cnam donc c'est pas non plus
les millions annoncés pour les cartes
vitale
de ces chiffres et estimations de la
fraude l'estimation de la fraude et ça
c'est des parlementaires et le ministère
est en cours donc franchement moi j'ai
vu beaucoup de choses circuler sur ces
sujets et qui sont bons mais je voudrais
rajouter parce que monsieur haddad est
l'occasion de s'exprimer simplement sur
la méthode évidemment je crois que le
gouvernement a fait preuve et fait
preuve actuellement grâce à ces
consultations elisabeth borgne a
commencé à consulter l'ensemble des
responsables de partis et de groupes
parlementaires pour justement tout à
fait d'accord changer une méthode
changer de méthode avec les politiques
changer de méthode avec les groupes
parlementaires changer de méthode à
l'assemblée nationale mais je suis
d'accord avec avec mon contradicteur ou
en tout cas avec le débatteur il faut
aussi changer de méthode avec les
collectivités faire beaucoup plus dans
cette concertation nécessaire que nous
avions souhaité et qui avait été
souhaité lors du grand débat dès 2019
mais qu'il faut absolument
refaire et en tout cas avoir mettre en
place est meilleure écoute je crois du
terrain avec ses cette décentralisation
et c'est étape de décentralisation qui
sont absolument nécessaires et que
personnellement et aussi avec le parti
auquel j'appartiens le modem nous nous
prônons depuis des années c'est à dire
cette concertation avec les
collectivités avec les acteurs de
terrain que ce soit les communes les
départements ou les régions et l heure
cela je rejoins complètement monsieur
haddad c'est un changement continuel de
méthodes de s'approcher au plus près du
terrain pour prendre les décisions jonas
haddad
vous êtes conseiller régional l'est
républicain de normandie vice-président
de la fondation concorde on est pas
d'accord avec isabelle florennes sur le
montant la facture de la fraude sociale
c'est vrai que c'est difficile de se
faire une idée précise par définition
puisque c'est de la fraude un
oui mais bon je pense qu'on n'a plus le
temps de tergiverser avec ces sujets là
vous savez je le gouvernement a une
fâcheuse tendance lorsqu'il ya une
difficulté à lancer une
une concertation un plan une mission une
lettre de mission une mission de l'être
je pense que sur ces sujets là il faut
trancher pourquoi parce que en fait on
n'a plus le temps
lorsque le taux d'intérêt pour emprunter
de la dette faut que notre auditeur
comprennent bien et à 0% bien sûr qu'on
peut faire le quoi qu'il en coûte on
peut emprunter sur les marchés pour
financer un train de vie qui ne va pas
mais lorsque notre train de vie dépend
de marché qui sont aujourd'hui à 2% et
donc on emprunte l'argent beaucoup plus
hachée avec eux donc ça nous coûte
beaucoup plus cher on n'a plus le temps
de tergiverser avec les façons dont on
fait des économies et d'ailleurs ça
revient à ce que dit madame tout à
l'heure vous avez parfaitement raison
heureusement qu'il ya des députés les
républicains et d'autres formations
politiques qui existent pourquoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui quand on a ces débats là
notamment et je suis ravi que vous
reconnaissiez sur le changement de
méthode on écoute parce qu'avant vous
avez parlé du grand débat on n'écoutait
pas est ce que quelqu'un peut me dire
une seule mesure qu'il est sorti du
grand débat est ce que quelqu'un peut me
dire qu'est ce qu'on a fait de tous et
carnet de doléances ça a été un très bel
échappatoire au moment de la crise du
gilet jaune pour retrouver de la
concertation mais qu'est ce qu'il en est
sorti de ce grand débat orient et qui
peuvent dire aujourd'hui ce qu'a produit
ce grand débat si pardon un moment il ya
eu une un comité citoyen qui avait qui
étaient composés d'énormément de
personnes qui avaient des visions
écologistes assez radicale et au final
ça s'est terminé en eau de boudin donc
ce qui est bien cette nouvelle méthode
que nous avons imposées c'est que
maintenant le blabla c'est un peu
terminée alors y héberger quand même
peut-être pas directement du grand débat
mais en tout cas de la crise des gilet
jaune c'est la retraite à 1000 euros
1100 euros très exactement c'est ce
qu'envisage de mettre en place emmanuel
macron avec cette fameuse réforme des
retraites qui sera débattue dans les
prochains mois là aussi à des postes il
ya des économies à faire isabelle
florennes ya surtout la réforme des
retraites que nous souhaitons c'est
surtout plus de justice vous parlez de
la revalorisation de la retraite
minimale à 1100 euros et c'est aussi
plus de justice plus de justice et nous
l'avons suffisamment 10 pour les femmes
pour les carrières hachées pour des
carrières longues
qu'il faut absolument
maintenir et donc avoir un certain
nombre de critères de pénibilité sur les
carrières longues et sur les carrières
hachées donc c'est une réforme avant
tout la réforme des retraites une
réforme de justice sociale qui in fine
et on verra quels sont les paramètres et
des conditions qui sont retenus c'est
l'objet avant tout je dois dire aussi
d'un changement de méthode qui sera une
méthode de se faire sur la base d'une
concertation qui va s'engager je
souhaite en tout cas c'est ce que la
première ministre a annoncé à l'automne
et sur lequel des discussions avec les
partenaires sociaux et l'ensemble des
français sera à mon avis essentiel
en tout cas il faut faire autrement que
ce qui a été fait mais rappelé que avant
tout avant de parler des pistes
d'économies elles existeront sûrement
mais avant tout il y à une
nécessité de revoir notre système qui
pour le moment produit encore trop d'un
du trop d'injustices donc ça c'est un
une première un premier choix une
première orientation de cette réforme
est effectivement ensuite c'est comme la
réforme de l'allocation chômage
ces cds piste effectivement d'économies
qui sont envisagées qui vont l'être et
qui vont être mis sur la table avec les
partenaires sociaux quand ça va bien
quand ça va mal on n'a pas les mêmes les
mêmes c'est le même système et je crois
que cette flexibilité
encadré me dis bien encadrés comme ce
sera le cas dans ce qui est proposé est
nécessaire maintenant nous reprenons
notre conversation après une courte
pause sur europe 1
le débat d'europe midi avec isabelle
floren porte parole du modem et jonas
haddad conseiller régional l'est
républicain de normandie également
vice-président de la fondation concorde
a tout de suite eu en europe un rappel
des levées
retour sur europe 1 isabelle floren
porte parole du modem est avec nous pour
le débat d'europe midi tout comme jonas
haddad conseiller régional l'est
républicain de normandie vice-président
de la fondation concorde nous traversons
un été difficile du point de vue
environnemental nous l'avons encore
entendus pendant le journal ces feux à
répétition
qui n'épargne aucun département de la
france on a vu des feux dans le morbihan
dans le finistère en isère encore hier
en charente ces dernières heures
également et dans ce budget 2023
isabelle florennes on a l'impression que
il n'y a pas tant que ça de fond de
moyens qui sont mis dans l'environnement
dans la transition écologique pourtant
l'un des trois piliers identifiés par
gabriel atteint le ministre des comptes
publics
3,3 milliards pour l'environnement s'est
présenté comme ça mais ça c'est si on
cumule les 1,9 milliard pour la
transition écologique les 500 millions
pour l'agriculture et les 900 millions
pour la cohésion des territoires vous
savez ce qu'ils vont vous dire vous
opposant écologistes vont vous dire
c'est un tour de passe passe oui enfin
ça c'est s'aider des cumuls de chiffres
ils sont quand même important il faut
quand même pas elle dira pas négligeable
quelque 200 millions d'euros dans la
cohésion des territoires tout va aller à
la transition écologique
contre les incendies par exemple c'est
souhaitable et c'est même ce qu'il
faudra que les députés
et les sénateurs vérifie quand le budget
sera examiné que cet argent est bien au
bon endroit il faut saluer quand même
vous parlez des incendies
les pompiers qui sont actuellement mis
sous pression
continuellement quasiment dans toutes
les régions françaises et et dire que
effectivement leurs moyens doivent être
renforcées notamment auprès des conseils
départementaux et des 10 sur le terrain
qui gère qui gère ce personnel et qui
gèrent leurs moyens et ils ont été la
sécurité civile également donc l'état
fait son travail sur le terrain depuis
depuis longtemps en renforçant les
moyens maintenant vous parlait
d'écologie et et c'est de ces chiffres
additionnés moi ce que je vois c'est
hiller 3 bien sûr mais c'est vrai que
c'est un poste de dépense aujourd'hui
l'écologie le développement et la
mobilité durable
24,9 milliards d'euros we always ce qui
est et ce qui est conséquent et surtout
un gouvernement qui au delà de ces
chiffres à une véritable volonté avec
une première ministre qui est elle-même
en charge d'appliquer le plan de
transition énergétique et écologique et
de développement durable avec des
ministres qui ont cette feuille de route
en transversalité sur l'ensemble des
ministères car maintenant c'est ça le
souhait de ce nouveau gouvernement
cesser d'avoir et d'appliquer à dans
chacun des ministères et a ensuite au
plus près du terrain dans chacune des
collectivités et dans chacune des
administrations territoriales de l'état
ce plan de transition au plus près des
besoins et de la nécessité de travailler
sur le terrain parce que c'est bien beau
de prendre des décisions vous savez bien
à paris si ensuite elles elles ne
peuvent pas où elles sont mal appliquées
sur le terrain ça sert à rien moi je
crois que les collectivités font
d'énormes efforts sur la transition
écologique depuis un certain nombre
d'années elle travail a des bonnes
expériences qui sont menées il ya une
conscience de la plupart des élus locaux
sur ces questions il ya des bonnes idées
aussi si vous regardez actuellement
énormément de collectivités de conseils
départementaux investissent sur des
revêtements
bien meilleure en termes de transition
écologique et retiennent moins la
chaleur
chaque collectivité j'appartiens conseil
municipal ans dans les hauts-de-seine et
d'autres villes des hauts-de-seine le
fond de travailler sur de nouveaux
revêtements c'est des investissements
très concret du quotidien qui sont
réadapter sur le terrain et nous on ne
croise à nous on croit à ce travail de
terrain accompagnés par l'état qui doit
être dans l'accompagnement et non pas
dans l'ain sanctions et c'est ça ce ce
travail qui doit être dans
l'accompagnement l'accompagnement vers
des énergies renouvelables
accompagnement vers des meilleurs
mobilité et des mobilités durables
accompagner aussi les plus modestes vers
la transition vers des véhicules propres
et également la rénovation des bâtiments
qu'ils soient publics ou particulier la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments ça
c'est des priorités qui ont été affichés
et présenté par le gouvernement et qui
valent qui vont me semble-t-il dans la
bonne direction jeune à sa date de votre
formation le parti des républicains a
toujours défendu renforcement de la
politique nucléaire c'est surtout là
qu'il faut investir selon vous pour bien
accélérer la transition écologique
va évidemment c'est je pense que tout le
monde aujourd'hui s'aperçoit et d'une
forme de tiers mondisation de la france
est-ce que de souvenirs j'allais dire
d'hommes
peut-être depuis la crise pétrolière on
se souvient qu on a un risque de black
out aujourd'hui dans notre pays qu'on
nous dit que il faut peut-être un peu
couper le wifi
faut peut-être faire attention et c est
qu on envisage d une possibilité d'être
en pénurie que
malheureusement par la décision d'avoir
fermer fessenheim qui était une décision
qui a été prise par françois hollande et
qui a été maintenu par emmanuel macron
eh bien on se retrouve aujourd'hui à
devoir rouvrir les centrales à charbon
en france et je vois pas en quoi c'est
beaucoup plus écologique que le
nucléaire qui est une énergie qu'il
n'est pas intermittente et qui ne paul
qui polluent finalement assez peu et je
pense que si on avait mis tous les
milliards qu'on avait mis dans
l'investissement pour des énergies qui
sont intéressantes par certains aspects
mais qui en réalité sont intermittentes
et qui gêne beaucoup les populations je
pense notamment aux éoliennes aux
panneaux solaires si on avait mis tout
ça dans le nucléaire bien aujourd'hui on
serait parce qu'on était avec la vision
du général de gaulle de l'époque les
champions du nucléaire avec aucun
problème d'énergie c'est d'autant plus
important autant pour l'écologie bien
évidemment que pour nos entreprises vous
savez en france on a un coût du travail
qui est très élevée on n'a pas forcément
les meilleures ressources mais on avait
une ressource qui était peu cher pour
les entreprises et qui leur permettait
d'être compétitive c'est l énergie et
même ça on a saboté le mix énergétique
et malheureusement c'est une des erreurs
si vous voulez de du gouvernement macron
notamment pendant les cinq dernières
années mais encore une fois la de ce
convoi est bien le fait d'avoir mis la
pression régulièrement fait
qu'aujourd'hui est bien le président un
république et son gouvernement font un
fonds en font un virage à 360 degrés
sauf sur les éoliennes ont continué de
maintenir les choses alors effectivement
je partage tout ce que dit votre
intervenante précédente aussi sur le
niveau je pense que c'est au niveau
local que
ça ça doit se faire je pense notamment à
ce qu'on a fait en normandie avec la
création d'un giec normand vous l'avez
vous en avez parlé de ce qui se font
dans les collectivités locales c'est
beaucoup plus à ce niveau là parce que
si vous voulez le niveau national pour
ces grandes politiques il faut s'en
méfier je vous donne un seul exemple
j'en terminerai par l'ars pour montrer
comment les écologistes ne sont vraiment
pas les mieux placés pour nous donner
des leçons en matière d'écologie le
grand incendie qui a eu à la teste de
buch pendant des semaines et des
semaines et bien il y causer et
maintenant c'est avéré principalement
par la demande d'une sénatrice
écologiste à ces idéologues qui depuis
paris avait demandé qu'on met en pause
le plan de gestion de la forêt et bien
résultat des courses le plan de gestion
la forêt n'a pas été appliqué et donc on
a eu ces incendies là donc en fait je
pense qu'il faut être vraiment au plus
proche du terrain sans idéologie
regardez j'allais dire cliniquement ce
qui fonctionne et ce qui ne fonctionne
pas pour qu'on aille dans des démarches
de développement durable mais qu'ils
soient pas des démarches idéologique
comme ont pu être la fermeture de la
centrale de fessenheim ou certains
délires un peu de certains écologistes
isabelle florent parler on est on est
d'accord sur au moins une chose qu'il
faut il faut écouter le terrain des
bonnes initiatives maintenant je peux
pas vous laisser dire qu' un virage à
360 degrés sans la politique énergétique
du gouvernement ni sur son
investissement dans le nucléaire qui est
d'ores et déjà mal une macro on s'est
mis à parler de franchement de nucléaire
à la fin de son premier quinquennat
peut-être ceci dit et et c'était une
petite divergence que nous avions entre
le modem françois bayrou notamment sur
ces questions effectivement nous avons
toujours eu une idée claire sur la
nécessité d'investir dans le nucléaire
en tout cas au modem et les centristes
on avait toujours été clair sur ses
objectifs mais le les investissements
sont engagés sur les nouveaux apn ya une
crise énergétique mais ça c'est pas
c'est quelque chose d'un malheureusement
qui nous arrive et qui impacte qui est
un pacte impactant dûe à la crise
notamment ukrainienne et à la guerre en
ukraine donc on peut pas nier je peux
pas laisser dire qu'il ya un virage à
360 degrés je peux pas laisser dire non
plus que la convention citoyenne pour le
climat n'a rien donné au contraire je
crois que associer les citoyens à cette
réflexion est une bonne chose qu'il faut
continuer à le faire et ce que va
continuer à faire le gouvernement avec
son conseil national de la refondation
démocratique en tout cas ce que nous
souhaitons dès la rentrée continuer à
travailler avec les citoyens sur ces
questions je crois que plus on les
associe il ya d'abord un souhait pour
d'être associés et puis un souhait de
prise de conscience au quotidien et
aussi trouver des meilleures idées avec
avec le terrain comme comme nous le
souhaitons tous avec les élus locaux
notamment qui souvent ont des
expériences concluantes sur les
questions notamment liées à la
transition énergétique et écologique en
général donc là dessus on est d'accord
mais moi je peux pas laisser dire non
plus que les investissements n'ont pas
été faits il ya des questions qui
doivent se régler sur le terrain la
question n'est au lien en fait partie je
suis je suis d'accord sur ces questions
je suis pas concerné puisque dans mon
département nous n'avons pas ces
questions qui se posent mais mais je
pense que là encore c'est c'est au plus
près du terrain dans la concertation et
avec un conte un accompagnement de
l'état de l'état territorial alors il
nous reste une minute trente quelques
secondes donc je vous en accorder à
chacun quelques unes pour que vous me
disiez puisque maintenant les vacances
parlementaires ont commencé en tout cas
les travaux en séance sont suspendus
jusqu'au 3 octobre que vous me disiez en
un mot ce que vous avez pensé donc des
premiers pas de cette session
parlementaire qui a début des buts et
après les dernières élections
législatives qui ont débouché donc sur
un hémicycle à l'assemblée nationale
totalement fragmenté sans majorité
relative honneur aux femmes
erin nouvelle configuration on a alors
un hameau je constate que les lois ont
été votées qu'il y a eu des cmp et une
cmp vous vous souriez
conclusive entre le sénat et l'assemblée
nationale ce n'est pas négligeable sur
le texte pouvoir d'achat et notamment
des belles avancées et ça il faut le
souligner c'est positif donc un
changement de méthode qui s'amorce et
moi je souhaite qu'ils puissent
poursuivre dans les mois qui viennent
notamment sur les questions budgétaires
les premiers pas de la session
parlementaire
était conclusif d'après isabelle flore
nsn
commission mixte paritaire sur le
question du pouvoir d'achat jonas haddad
qu'elle vous revient quand vous voyez de
l'extérieur 1 lille a dit l'hôte naître
députés un
vigilance vigilance parce que d'un côté
on a des pour moi des nouveaux élus qui
sont très dangereux qui sont lésés du
danube est ce qu'ils ont pris des
positions ces derniers 30 ces derniers
temps qu'ils sont vraiment à l'opposé de
ce qu'on peut attendre en matière de
développement économique de cohésion de
notre pays
et vigilance aussi l'avis du
gouvernement qui ont le sens temps en
temps peut avoir des regrets si vous
voulez de un peu d'arrogance et nous
sommes là pour essayer de dégager vers
des solutions constructives dont
vigilance reprise des travaux le 3
octobre prochain au palais bourbon merci
isabelle floren porte partiel modem
merci jonas haddad conseiller régional
l'est républicain de normandie également
vice-président de la fondation concorde
merci à vous d'avoir suivi cette
nouvelle édition de rock midi je vous
retrouve ce soir pour eux europe soir ça
sera de 18 heures à 20 heures à tout à
l'heure sur eux